&gt;&gt; So the project that you're best known for
when you were a graduate student is this Brooke Project.
So can you tell us a little bit about that?
And this was a very important step in sort of the progression of GPU computing
to something that we can do commercially today.
&gt;&gt; Yeah, back in the Direct X 9 days of computer graphics,
GPUs started becoming truly programmable.
People could express real programs, fairly short ones, maybe only 4 to 8 instructions long,
that can actually solve a shading problem
like face, skin, shade, fairly complicated stuff.
A bunch of us in academia
noticed that the performance of these GPUs was huge
compared to CPUs of the day.
The number of floating point operations you could do was an order of magnitude larger.
So we studied and looked at how you could use GPUs
for more general purpose things
by hacking graphics APIs like Direct X.
The research--a lot of people showed that was doable.
>> But it was really hard. >> It was really hard to program.
In fact, you needed a PhD in computer graphics
to do even basic mathematical kind of stuff.
In fact, there were folks in finance that were hiring
game programmers to try to hack GPUs to solve financial problems.
The research I did was basically study the more fundamental programming model around GPUs.
What was it about GPUs that made them programmable and parallel
but also present a more cohesive program model
to general programmer
to let them think about GPUs in a more general way.
In the end, the project was called Brook.
It was an actual software programming language
for how to program in a general way GPUs
on top of its existing graphic APIs
so that users could think about more general data concepts
instead of triangles and pixels and textures.
&gt;&gt; What sort of things did people write in Brook?
&gt;&gt; We wrote Raytracer to sort of study
could a GPU actually implement a Raytracer,
which is a fun thing, because lot of people said it couldn't be done.
We did triangle meshing.
We did a lot of simulation and grid kinds of stuff,
thermodynamic problems, heat transfer problems, fluid flow kinds of problems.
For the most part, it worked.
It demonstrated the performance benefit.
It was still early.
They weren't fully general,
so you did have to work around some of the hiccups,
but from a research perspective,
it achieved its goal of showing the potential of GPU computing.